huge expectation as the king entered a
packed Parliament this was a moment for
the Monarch to deliver
and for 23 minutes that's what he did
foreign
speaking mostly in German he talked of
World War II and the late Queen's role
renewing relations
foreign
from past conflicts to current and
strong words on Ukraine
the angry Ukraine
foreign
and there was light relief too from
football to Monty Python and perhaps
most importantly for the last 50 years
we have loved together
both at each other and with each other
the first British monarch to address the
bundestad and for the chamber he'd met
the moment
The King's Speech felt personal this was
a message of historic friendship and
Alliance no mention of brexit or
division it is the UK looking forward
and focusing on the future
the king is known for his concern about
Ukraine and to that he visited this
Immigration Center helping those who've
recently fled
other engagements in tune with the
themes of this visit celebrating culture
bridges in more ways than one the king
with this joint German and British army
unit
but perhaps
just relaxed here getting a feel for
Germany's organic farming Laura bundock
Sky News in Berlin